the evidence would support if you're
young and training and you're getting
dietary protein whether it is from plant
or animal you could do either or that's
just for a muscle mass and strength
standpoint there aren't long-term
studies that are controlled it just
doesn't exist professionally I do not
believe that that is possible I think
that we have to really think about food
as a food Matrix I don't know you could
supplement creatine you could supplement
taurine but it's almost the same thing
as saying well I don't really need to
eat fruits and vegetables or
phytonutrients as long as I'm getting it
in a pill I think it would be impossible
to do all of that animal-based proteins
are rich they are highly bioavailable
but your original question is could we
could someone reach the optimal level of
Health without eating animal products I
think professionally
um I I'm not sure how someone would do
that